yeah I also don't know if I have a
healthy relationship with myself too
though hey let's give him space guys go
ahead and talk about
[Music]
it welcome back to careful boys we are
very careful boys and today we're
talking about so like a lot of people do
a lot of cool stuff in here right but
how do we keep ourselves in
check oh what do you mean how do you
keep yourself in check stop yourself
from robbing police no like you you go
that's hard yes that's the that's the
hard
question okay I'm very proud of myself
cuz I didn't punch the cab driver while
he was driving cuz it was okay think
about the bigger picture here if I punch
him in the face not only am I on camera
but he might put everyone in danger yep
so that's how I kept myself plus you're
a business owner you could give Su more
things to lose more things to lose like
that no so like you know how like you
Dell's bodybuilding [__] and like golly
swords and [__] yeah was that's a big up
right that's a big high you could you
could be a real suck piece of [__] after
that start going up to people like who
the [__] are you I'm stronger than you
I'm bigger than you and [__] the swords
you got I would have walked around with
swords everywhere everywhere right I
would have had it on both
sides just rolling the wrist dude
everywhere like this [__] just always
going everywhere like right you could be
a real prick Bart so what keeps you in
check what keeps you from being a real a
real what keeps you a humble man how do
you dominate humbly yeah cuz I I want it
in
Fresno oh yeah that's true you're
already there mentally that's healthy sh
out like you I'd be like I'm the king of
Fresno
I Fresno runs through here dude that's
what makes us boring yeah is we don't
lean into what we have to be doing like
like he should have been gloating like I
worked so [__] hard as the king of
Fresno dude you should have wrote like
17 paragraphs about like what you
achieved and [__] like that with a
picture of you doing this [__] I want
you to lean into it like look at what
I've done to get this [__] B look at
my accomplishment no he did it the right
way he's like purchased this program
that got me here but you have a picture
imagine having a picture on your
Instagram of all your opponents like I
dominated this person this person this
person having x's over their face like
stamped it's not enough to just get
first place but you have to step on
people that's it yeah step on their
[__] don't just dunk break the
[__] backboard shatter the glass yeah
right I see what you're saying I feel
like we don't have that mentality to
start off with not really no I think we
keep ourselves and check pretty good
right it's like you know what it is
remember like when you were starting out
in like uh acting or Hollywood and then
you had friends that would post like a
photo of them on set they had a very
small role but then they're caption was
like loved that the director came up to
me and said how well I did and it's like
like people would stretch the mozzarella
really [__] far but like now like
with us I think when you do something
it's like oh yeah I did that true but
it's not like I don't know that is true
it's like how do you keep yourself in
check so you're not [__] your head's
blowing up I mean we we also like in
here particularly set the bar so [__]
low that when we like kind of bounce
back with like 30,000 subscribers we get
[__] tattoos from
so that's probably the biggest Flex that
was that was 200,000 subscribers that's
a lot 2 million no I'm saying like where
it was yeah where it was like where it
came from it's not like we started at
zero we were at like 1.
n97 yeah we went up like 25,000
subscribers celebrating achievement
around
here but is it always like cuz you're
thinking of the next bigger goal that
you can achieve is that like you you
dominated president now you got to
dominate Downey right right I don't even
know if I think like
that step one get
Fresno step two get Bakersfield and then
the [__]
County California City I'm coming dude
California City no way that's
unachievable and then like the top of
the top is Reno Las Vegas we just see
like a shitty map with dominoes falling
everywhere yeah I'm telling yeah keep
yourself check is I feel like maybe it's
like the motivations different I feel
like uh there's like people that are
expressed outwardly maybe and I think
for me it's more so like like you
[__] little piece of [__] and so I
think it's like it's more me trying to
like I think we're all like that do stop
yeah I think proba that's what like like
you know like let's say if we if for
somehow we win like a Oscar or something
it'd be more like that's what I [__]
told you you could do it you son of a
[__] you finally lived up your
potential you're on the outside it's oh
thanks guys you know this is really cool
thank you everyone for supporting and
then versus the people that's like
posting all day cuz they are they're
trying to get this so they can show the
world but I think it's like at least for
my own personal motivation it's I'm
trying to do things to show myself like
see you [__] little piece of [__] I
[__] told you should have believed in
yourself in the beginning you know yeah
like barot an Oscar you take the trophy
like put it on the ground here somewhere
for like 6 years I know we had all of
our [__] Awards we had it stack y
yeah yeah it's true that was the number
one comment that somebody would make if
they've never been to the studio before
and they'd be like so like what's with
the pile of awards over here you do
especially like other tubers yeah yeah
aren't you guys proud of that you guys
are going to hang this up you I'm sure
we could find a wall that's what you
could keep saying also I could see Bart
though like being very very as cliche as
it is about the journey right like this
guy like he he gets [__] bodybuilding
Awards and then he's already all like
the biggest challenge I have yet to do
[__] post this whole announcement
stuff and and I was [__] talking to
him uh earlier because he I went to a
spot and he know [__] like snowing
and [__] like that right he works out
outside like a [__]
tool I don't have any other space to put
that stuff oh get a bigger house idiot
17th forever home right and then and
then I was like I was like dude it's
[__] cold out here what do you do
he's like check out this heater I bought
for like 100 bucks right so he's got
this heater Black Friday let's go he got
this he got this heater on Black Friday
right about that you have an outdoor
heater hey don't get cocky man the
propane kinds at the restaurant the
funny thing is now now he's posting on
his IG stories how he's like wiping snow
off his bench and stuff and he's doing
all these workout he's dancing around
I'm like why don't you turn all the
[__] heater it's not even on he's
like no because like if I turn it on
then I'm going to get used to it and I
don't want to be used to it I was like
so you just bought this thing to [__]
[__] with your discipline I don't want
to be a [__] so I I buy it I buy it so
I know there's like like salvation yeah
but if I get close to it I'm like you
sucking [__] get back over there I snow
I get snow I put in my save 100 bucks
and take a picture of one and [__]
put it on the
wall [__] is wrong with you save 100 but
I don't he's a method trainer cuz I
don't know about that until it happens
you know what me like when I'm there I'm
like o I should get a heater and then I
go and I buy it so it's like in the
moment then I buy the Heat and I put it
there and as as I get close I'm like
what are you doing you [__] little
[__] I'm like you're right you're right
stay away I think he's just different I
think he's just different yeah okay all
all right that's funny Bart buys a nice
mattress he's sleeping on a [__]
mattress he puts the nice mattress on
the wall and every time he thinks about
he's like oh no I don't need it I got
the shitty one I want to get used to it
it's like a Murphy bed that he W put
down like he locks it puts a
padlock how do I be extra
uncomfortable sleep on a water bed hey
if that's your method it's working so
yeah [__] keep keep talking [__] to
yourself so the answer to to Bart how
does Bart keep himself in check he goes
like this all day
you wrong you stupid [__] [__]
what do you do to the [__] deserve do
you guys feel like you could relate that
though like in your head yeah you're
always just talking so much [__] I just
feel if I ever it's like it's like Bart
saying about winning an Oscar if I ever
won an Oscar I'd be up there and I'd be
like I guess I just give these things
away to me that's like it's not cool if
you it's not cool if you're like I so
proud of myself like that's not cool and
and in my family if you ever do anything
like that oh you're so proud of yourself
huh oh yeah oh okay I got four siblings
or three siblings that take me down
immediately right right yeah that was
like me for me growing up it was always
that it's like my just the ball busting
nature of my family that's why I love
ball busters that's why we're all ball
busters and I love it but like that
that's I love that [__] also my wife's a
ball buster love that [__] so hey thank
you uh so yeah I'm surrounded by it I'm
surrounded by it and I and I like it and
like I know yeah it's it's healthy I
think I think it's healthy too I think
most of those things things right it's
like um so one how like where do you get
your validation from and two who's the
governing committee so like a lot of it
I just never saw the value cuz it's not
just skill and most of the times it's a
lot of politics it's a lot of you know
you're pulling this string so then if
this movie wins then um you can get like
another job after that or like there's
special interests that kind of benefit
from your movie winning because they
worked on this and it's like lot of glad
handing yeah so then it's so muddy to
like it's not just skill right like you
you want a dance competition it's not
just skill we could win we couldn't win
one cuz it's so rigged H yeah it's
[__]
rigged so I'm like a lot of those things
can't relate it's hard to be like oh I
[__] got it and that's why I'm the
best but it's like yeah but those three
judges you know they had so and so in
their pocket and it's like that didn't
really yeah I mean yeah so you got one
but did you really get one do you ever
feel jealous of like the rock though cuz
the rock like basically all day social
media is like I am [__] awesome yeah
and like tomorrow his post is like I'm
so
awesome it's like broke the record for
this but still hardest worker in the
room killing it right now burning that
midnight o every day is that all suppos
yeah like I but it's sick though yeah
sick and it's so in line with a
wrestling Persona too it's such a like
it's still in line with everything yeah
but it's also like he in that anomaly
where like the rock plays an actor in a
movie but it's like that's the rock
right the actor playing you he has to be
the rock even when he's [__] Tooth
Fairy you know what type of crazy
confidence that I actually like is um is
that boxer [__] talk like like Muhammad
Ali like I'm the [__] best this and
that and then they like rhyme with it
and I'm like oh now that that's healthy
confidence okay I like that yeah I like
as long as you get a rhyme in
there like a me Bumblebee
I'm a bumblebee I'll [__] you up I'm the
best I'm the greatest I'm the greatest I
ever live that sounds really a fortune
cookie now dude Mayweather social media
is great yeah he just posts
racks yeah yeah he's got like he takes
the trade table down like by the way
during takeoff too cuz you know he can
do that he can do that and then he's got
like a whole thing of cash just on the
trade table and he's just like some cat
falls down he puts it back up and that's
that's his post so how do you like for
for yourself let's say that um let's say
you're talking to some dudes right and
they don't know how much you accomplish
in terms of like writing films and
things like that and then they start
kind of sounding like they think you've
never done anything how do you bring up
that you have without sounding like
you're a [__] idiot I don't I I lean
into that I don't know anything I'm with
Steve on that too I'm with Steve but
what if but what if there's like an
opportunity depending on it
slightly uh opportunity oh like if I was
to say that I do there's some kind of
opportunity that comes out of it oh like
it's the next big job yeah like if
you're around some guys that could you
know like or or like you're hired to
like actually public speak at like a
college for all the accomplishments you
made so you can't just talk about how
you don't know [__] you actually have to
inspire you know I would I would
probably I don't know you know what one
of the funniest things I ever saw was um
I was at VidCon many years ago and Kyle
Mooney from Good Neighbor he he gave he
gave a speech about how
you know eating [__] is like different
Carl's junr menu items and like and that
was I think if if I got hired for one of
those College things I think it's
something like that some kind of like
long form Ted talk about something that
doesn't it's unrelated yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's he's the guy that was like
that's so gay dude yeah he's that guy
right into his bedroom or whatever the
hot guy babes and he did that he dude he
did that bit and the guys who were
putting on a VidCon at the time like the
Green Brothers they like came out and
did this public post about how like it's
like the least funny thing that's ever
happened to VI I'm like first of all
dude you guys are not exactly known for
being humorous
people just chill out a little bit like
and I I publicly defended him I was like
dude that was you know one of the
funniest things and go figure uh at a
time when really nobody's really funny
on YouTube somebody actually does
something funny on YouTube and then he
get they get punished for it and then uh
uh but that that I think that's more in
line with yeah yeah I also don't know if
I have a healthy relationship with
myself too
though
squinty hey let's give him space guys go
ahead and talk about it bar just don't
say you have anxiety don't [__] say
it so I've done like power thing I've
done quite a few competitions in the
last 10 years right and I'll see people
like let's say they win or however they
do I feel like their expression matches
the result oh and I'm like oh that's
healthy like when someone like does does
something they've been working really
hard at they finally get whatever they
wanted to do they're like they go like
that right yes or whatever bar got a not
good enough mentality yeah I always feel
like um like let's say if I win third I
can't wait to go to the podium cuz I
think it's the funniest thing in the
world and then if I win first I almost
go okay let's let's leave and just just
tell the that's right though that's the
right answer tell tell the ref tell the
ref to send it to me cuz it feels so
like weird like I'm the best I I was the
best this one you know so I felt like I
feel
so so I'm like I don't know if it's like
even healthy know do I accept myself you
know what I mean like I don't know it's
I wish I could just be like oh [__] you
you got good here just like yes but I
feel like it feels weird that's like
that Tiger Woods video where he putts
and then he doesn't even look at it he
turns to his buddy he's like yeah yeah
dude
that's and it goes in he's walking away
already people go like this and they
turn around that's [__] gang so sick
but for me but for us we prefer like we
go like that we turn around and and the
ball just
airballs doesn't go near it and we're
walking yeah yeah St
back there's these there's this thing
that bothers me and probably only
bothers me but it's that jiujitsu
tournaments cuz it's like you get all
ages there right but then you get guys
who are like who are just starting doing
Jiu-Jitsu which is totally fine that's
not the problem that's not the issue
that I have with it but it's it's like
they compete they win their gold medal
which is tight but then they wear it
around the [__] a they're so proud
they're proud 100% but also like I think
in my head you get 10 minutes with you
walking around with it and then you got
to put it away bro you win gold you got
to put your medal away if your
opponent's wearing it can you use it to
take them
down you got to P choke him with it but
but if you got bronze you can wear that
[__] all day right Nah if you're a grown
if you're a grown person if you're grown
and you win a medal you put it away I'm
going to wear all my medals to everyone
I think I have to but it's only CU I
don't take it that seriously see that
particular one is not my sport my thing
that I worked hard on exactly so even
won yet it wouldn't matter to me but
then it matters to you cuz you put so
much work in as the thing that you like
see I'd have to like trip and fall and
like find my way in this competition and
then I'd wear it everywhere and be like
[__] you guys you guys suck I think if
and when woo hits jackpot Steve's just
going to turn this into actual gold and
still wear it he's just not going to
wear it anymore I'm going to ice in the
[__] up you're probably right I probably
probably would just stop wearing he's
going to tattoo we're going to know when
Steve sells dude yeah you will you will
the new Rebrand will be interesting
let's go the funny thing though is all
of us are pretty competitive that's why
like we win a lot of [__] but then the
thing that makes us competitive isn't
what makes other people like want that
first place or whatever I don't think it
ever was about first place
yeah it's about the Love of the Game
well it's about stunting on on haters
stunting on haters stunting on haters
Love of the Game bro I like the Love of
the Game I think the game is fun but you
got to dominate somehow so I think
humbly yeah the game isn't just so or or
else you would have maybe done a thing
that's alone you know what I mean like
something that's like I don't know like
what's aone sport like bodybuilding
running well your body you're still
competing and running is still marathons
and stuff you're still like comp so what
is something that's just no audience all
by yourself solit tournament Solitaire
tournament should be bowling there's
nobody in the audience I think oh what
about the guy that oh this is a perfect
example the guy who bow 300 and he goes
ah I [__] did
it did
it did I love that guy dude but but like
he has he has the right to be like I bow
a perfect [__] game and somebody has
to do it cuz there's nobody in the
audience clapping or anything but why is
that video viral is because he's going
insane and that's why of people do 300 I
thought it was or at a competition maybe
I don't know a lot of people get black
belts and Sanders are quite low these
days I I love I do love seeing other
people have that moment yeah I don't
know why that is it makes me feel so
good yeah like when you watch the
[__] cup stack guys they're like [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the kid who won
Tetris recently dude I love that I love
that video it's like oh yeah he broke
the game little kid beat Tetris and then
some [__] Australian newscaster tried
to talk [__] and act like it wasn't
achievement you no some like Australian
news lady was like uh that's not a real
achievement was like I would say go
outside like she had some [__] to
say [__] you read the news you read you
[__] read he we read we read the news
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but um [__] we get it wrong though
we get
it I like seeing other I love seeing
other people [__] overreact to their
wins it's [__] sick yeah well real
reckon that's real y saying so when you
actually see authentic victories it's
like that's kind of the sickest thing
ever but you guys didn't even win though
like [__] Skrillex took that that cup
stacking oh my God and turned into a
[__] song turned into turned into a
drop yeah cuz it was so real that it was
just like [__] this is like hype I wish
I could experience that
though I I I do maybe just compete
outside of FR what's even better is
you'll experience it through ta I think
I think so too I think that's more
valuable anyway cuz like let's say when
and Joe crossed a million for one of our
channels I don't even think we even knew
it was like someone made might have told
us like oh cool you guys want
JJs tell you what we knew when we hit 2
million you know what I'm saying you do
you guys celebrate achievements like
I've I don't think I celebrate any
achievements I think we're supposed to
though but that's a troll like that's I
mean not a troll this is an achievement
though kind of yeah cuz you have
mosquito bites on you got new bites
around it too damn man why you got that
oh my goodness mine's healing hey yours
is kind of fire now though dude it looks
good good it's cold out here you know
what I'm saying I'm just saying it's a
little asy I got mine removed but were
you at I show mine but mine's not there
anymore the double still gets me every
time
D I always forget there's two dude that
is just insane I think people
congratulate and celebrate more for us
than we do for ourselves but I wish I
could I feel like I'm unhealthy or
something well if you were to die
tomorrow though on your deathbed
thinking about the million things that
you would probably think of that are
more important than celebrating yourself
would celebrating yourself get on that
list no keep you thinking about TI [__]
you know that's why I said the million
things I know but you already know you
already know I feel like it's it's it's
not worthy of Celebration yet for some
reason it it feels like then you'll
never celebrate cuz you're probably
going to always have that feeling but
then how do you teach taica to enjoy his
victory oh dude I don't need to he does
he's like oh yes spelled b oh sting like
a bee
bumblebee I don't need to he
has he spelled the letter but you're not
but you're not doing the [__] that
you're trying to do so you can celebrate
or his behavior chart he's supposed to
get like I think between 50 and 55 and
I'm like dude what happened you only got
like 42 today he's like better than
17 17's like expulsion
bro so positive yeah that's good that's
great nothing's going to keep that kid
in check yeah better than 17 he's kind
of right he's absolutely
right